What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Inst. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, welcome to another Friday Chit Chat.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由 Instacart 购物专员精心挑选并送到你门前、在烧烤架上滋滋作响的大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能下单的完美肋眼牛排。不管你的夏天需要采购什么杂货，Instacart 都能满足你。下载 Instacart 应用，前三单即可享受 0 美元配送费。服务费、排除条款和相关条件适用。Inst. Instacart，送货超出期待的杂货配送。你好，欢迎收听又一期的周五闲聊。
Hi, we have a fun little guest in the studio with us. So we have Sam, we have Cassie, and then we have Colin who worked with us at Earwolf. Colin, say hi. Hey. Colin's visiting and we have forced him to come in the studio and be on mic with you today. Yeah, I hope being on microphone. I like listening to podcasts, watching podcasts, not talking on podcasts. You're going to do just fine.
嗨，我们工作室里有一位有趣的小嘉宾。这里有萨姆、卡茜，还有曾在 Earwolf 和我们一起工作的科林。科林，打个招呼吧。嘿。科林来做客，我们强行把他拉进工作室，今天和你一起在麦克风前聊天。对，我希望上麦……我喜欢听播客、看播客，但不喜欢在播客里说话。你表现会很好的。
Great. Angela, you said you have a share. Well, I do. OK, so a while back, there was an article in The New Yorker, and it was called, Why Do We Still Love the Office? And it had an illustration for the article. It's of everyone in the bullpen. And Jenna, I loved it because right front and center
太棒了。安吉拉，你说你有一个分享。嗯，我有。好吧，不久前，《纽约客》上有一篇文章，题目是《为什么我们依然热爱〈办公室〉？》。文章配有一幅插图。画的是办公区里的所有人。杰娜，我太喜欢了，因为就在最前面正中间
are Pam and Angela. Angela even has one of her cats. I'm gonna put this in our stories. Do you see that? Yes. Okay, well, I just kind of became obsessed with it because I mean, our two characters are the front two characters and that so rarely happens for us in any kind of artwork
是帕姆和安吉拉。安吉拉甚至还抱着她的一只猫。我要把它发到我们的动态里。你看到了吗？看到了。好的，我有点对它着迷了，因为我是说，我们两个角色是排在最前面的两个角色，这在为《办公室》创作的任何艺术作品中
that's done for the office. So I found the artist and his name is Max Dalton and he does a lot of illustrations. And I DMed him on Instagram and I said, is there any way I can get a copy of this drawing? I love it so much. And he was like, absolutely. And he sent me this note.
都是极其罕见的。所以我找到了这位艺术家，他叫马克斯·道尔顿，他创作了许多插画。我在 Instagram 上给他发私信说，我有什么办法能买到这幅画的复制品吗？我太喜欢了。他回复说，当然可以。然后他给我发了这张便条。
He said, dear Angela, here's two copies of my illustration of the office. Because I asked if I could have one for you too. Stop it. And he said, as you know, the illustration was made only for an article in The New Yorker. So it's unfortunately quite small. And then he put in parentheses, would
他说，亲爱的安吉拉，这是两份我的《办公室》插画复制品。因为我问过是否也可以为你留一份。别闹了。他说，如你所知，这幅插画是专为《纽约客》的一篇文章创作的。所以遗憾的是它非常小。然后他在括号里写道，
that's what she said apply here? And then he wrote on to say, I hope that's not too disappointing. Thanks to you and Jenna and the rest of the cast for all the hilarious moments. Love, Max. Oh my gosh. Yes, and now you and I each have one. I love that lady that is so sweet. It's so beautiful.
“这句话是她说的”在这里适用吗？接着他又写道，希望这不会太令人失望。感谢你、杰娜以及其他演员带给我们的所有搞笑时刻。爱你的，马克斯。噢天哪。是的，现在你和我都各有一份。我真喜欢这位女士，太贴心了。太漂亮了。
I love his drawing. I just think it captures everything. And you even have prison Mike on the computer screen. So I'll share that in my stories, but I just thought I had to give Max a thank you here on the podcast because that was so wonderful of him. Do you know about the artist that goes to thrift stores and buys paintings and then he like paints people into them? Like he repurposes thrift art. Okay, so he took some thrifted painting of the last supper
我喜欢他的画。我觉得它抓住了所有精髓。而且电脑屏幕上甚至还有监狱迈克。所以我会把它分享到我的动态里，但我只是觉得我必须在播客里对马克斯表达感谢，因为他太好了。你知道那个去旧货店买画然后把人物画进去的艺术家吗？就是他会改造旧货艺术品。好吧，他买了一幅旧货市场的《最后的晚餐》油画，
and he painted the office into it. So like on the table, there's like a stapler and jello, but then all of our characters are in the painting. And I saw his reel as he was doing it. And I made a comment where I said, oh my gosh, I would love this. This is amazing. And he, I guess, wrote me back and said, you can have it.
然后把《办公室》的角色画了进去。所以就像在桌子上，有钉书机和果冻，然后我们所有的角色都在这幅画里。我看了他创作时的视频短片。我留了言，说哦天哪，我太想要这个了。这太棒了。然后他好像回了我信，说你可以拥有它。
But I guess I didn't see his message in time and he ended up selling it. Aw. But his stuff is really cool. It's really fun. This in Nowhere is of the same magnitude of that really cool piece of art passing you by. Yes.
但我想我没有及时看到他的信息，他最后把它卖掉了。啊。但他的作品真的很酷。非常有趣。这绝对和那个与你擦肩而过的超级酷的艺术品是同一个量级的。是的。
But do you guys remember when I found out that there's a mustard wine by Grey Poupon? Yes. Yes. It's a long time ago and for podcast listeners, well, I guess Grey Poupon reached out to us to send us their mustard wine and I never saw the DM. And you missed it.
但是你们还记得我发现灰 poupon 有一款芥末酒的时候吗？记得。记得。那是很久以前的事了，对于播客听众来说，嗯，我想灰 poupon 联系了我们，要给我们寄他们的芥末酒，但我从来没看到那条私信。而你错过了。
And now I can't find it. I don't know where it's like buried in the DMs. Jenna, that guy's name is Tyler Turnbull. Oh, thank you, Sam! Tyler Turnbull Art. Tyler Turnbull. Okay, well, we'll share about him in our stories. Yeah, and I hope Grey Poupon reaches back out to you. Yeah, Grey Poupon, it's not too late. Yeah, come back over.
现在我找不到了。我不知道它被埋在私信的哪个角落了。杰娜，那个家伙的名字叫泰勒·特恩布尔。哦，谢谢你，萨姆！泰勒·特恩布尔艺术。泰勒·特恩布尔。好吧，我们会在动态里分享他的信息。对，我希望灰 poupon 能再次联系你。对，灰 poupon，现在还不算晚。对，再联系我们吧。
We'll try your mustard wine. Well, on this same subject, you know, after Lindsay Broad was on our podcast and she talked about true fruit and how much she loves the chocolate covered fruit from true fruit. Yeah. They sent her a whole box of true fruit. That's awesome. She is so delighted. I was texting with her about it. She just texted me a photo of a giant box of true fruit. And I was like, what is happening? And how did this happen? How did this occur?
我们会尝尝你们的芥末酒的。好吧，说到这儿，你知道的，在林赛·布罗德上我们的播客并谈论了真水果（True Fruit）以及她多么喜欢真水果的巧克力包裹水果之后。对。他们给她寄了一整箱真水果。太棒了。她太高兴了。我和她发短信聊过这事。她刚给我发了一张真水果大箱子的照片。然后我就想，发生什么了？这怎么发生的？这到底是怎么做到的？
This is a really hard segue. But as you were saying that, all I could think of is like, there's got to be something, Collin, you can take to help pass your kidney. Oh, no. Oh, no. Some sort of chocolate-covered fruit to help it pass through. That's all I could think of.
这是一个非常生硬的过渡。但当你说这话时，我脑子里想的全是，科林，你肯定有什么办法能把你的肾结石排出来。哦，不。哦，不。某种能帮助它排出的巧克力水果。我脑子里全在想这个。
I was like, I'm so sorry. We're actually surprised you made it in today. I mean, Jenna and I have been texting you, and you shared with us. And you said it's OK to talk about it. Absolutely. Yeah. You have a kidney stone.
我就想，真对不起。其实我们挺惊讶你今天能来的。我是说，杰娜和我一直在跟你发短信，你跟我们分享了。而且你说过可以公开谈论这个。当然可以。对。你得了肾结石。
Yeah, we were meant to be meeting Monday, and I called in sick from urgent care. I know. But I sent you an article, Colin, and this is true. Guys, this is not like internet nonsense. Like, this isn't like some reel on the gram. This is a real article where they found that people with kidney stones, if they ride the roller coaster
对，我们本打算周一开会，我从急诊室请了病假。我知道。但我给你发了一篇文章，科林，这是真的。伙计们，这不是网上那种胡说八道。这不是那种网上的短视频。这是一篇真实的他们发现的研究文章，研究表明肾结石患者如果去坐过山车
Big Thunder Mountain Railroad, they pass their kidney stones. Is it something about how it twists and turns? Yes, yes it is. Colin, did you go to Disney Learn yesterday? I didn't. I wondered if I could like claim it back on my healthcare. That seemed like it'd be an excellent like deduction. Yeah, medically speaking you need to go. Yeah, do you have an HSA card? Are you in pain? Yeah, a little bit. I just took some more painkillers. I'm so sorry.
巨雷山铁路（Big Thunder Mountain Railroad），就能排出肾结石。是因为它那些扭转和弯道吗？对，是的。科林，你昨天去迪士尼学习了吗？我没有。我在想我是不是能把它报进我的医疗保险里。这似乎可以算是一个极好的抵扣项目。对，从医学上讲你需要去。对，你有 HSA（健康储蓄账户）卡吗？你疼吗？对，有一点。我刚又吃了点止痛药。我很抱歉。
But it seems to come and go. And it's particularly bad overnight, because I'm one of those tornado sleepers that just keeps spinning around. I'm like that, too. And really what I need to do is just lay still. Oh, no. You need to get a cat, and then the cat will sleep on you,
但它似乎时好时坏。而且夜里特别严重，因为我是那种像龙卷风一样在床上一直翻来滚去的睡觉姿势。我也是那样。其实我需要做的就是一动不动地躺着。哦，不。你需要养只猫，然后猫会睡在你身上，
and then you can't turn. Cassie, that's your answer to everything. And that's deductible, right? Yeah. Colin, I pulled up the article. I want everyone to know this information, and I really want to go to Disneyland with you. It says that it has a 70% success rate, but not every rollercoaster works. That
这样你就不能翻身了。卡茜，这是你对所有问题的答案。而且这可以报税抵扣，对吧？对。科林，我把文章找出来了。我想让每个人都知道这个信息，而且我真的很想跟你一起去迪士尼乐园。上面说它的成功率有 70%，但并不是每一种过山车都管用。
in particular, the Big Thunder Mountain Railroad is the most successful. This group of doctors, they took a 3D model of a hollow kidney containing three kidney stones on the ride in a backpack 20 times. And when they sat in the very last car of the railroad, like you have to sit in the last, don't sit in the front. If you sit in the back, there's a 64% passage rate. If you sit in the front, there's only a 16% success rate. But they expanded their study and they used even more kidney models.
特别是巨雷山铁路是最成功的。这群医生把一个包含三颗肾结石的空心肾脏 3D 模型放在背包里，坐了 20 次过山车。当他们坐在过山车的最后一排时——你必须坐在最后一排，不要坐在前面。如果你坐在后面，结石排出率是 64%。如果你坐在前面，成功率只有 16%。但他们扩大了研究范围，使用了更多的肾脏模型。
And the second time they did it, when they sat in the back, it was a 70% success rate. They said, in all, we used 174 kidney stones of varying shapes, sizes, and weights to see if each model worked on the same ride. And Big Thunder Mountain Railroad was the only one that worked. They tried Space Mountain
他们第二次做实验时，坐在后排的成功率达到了 70%。他们说，总共我们使用了 174 颗形状、大小和重量各不相同的肾结石，来观察每个模型在同一辆过山车上是否都管用。而巨雷山铁路是唯一管用的。他们尝试了太空山
and Aerosmith's Rock and Roller Coaster, but those failed. He said it has something to do with the twists and turns. And he said if you have a kidney stone but are otherwise healthy and meet the requirements of the ride, you should try it. Sounds like a great doctor's day out, right? I know. To convince you at university that you should go to Disneyland.
和史密斯飞船摇滚过山车，但都失败了。他说这跟过山车的扭转和弯道有关。他说如果你有肾结石，但除此之外身体健康并且符合过山车的要求，你应该去试试。听起来是个很棒的医生一日游，对吧？我知道。在大学里说服你应该去迪士尼乐园。
And just ride this roller coaster how many times? And we'll need to try them all as well just to make sure it works. Also, the Aerosmith one is in Orlando, so they got the budget to fly to Florida to test their experiment. I think they actually only tested this in Florida. So I do wonder Colin. You are s*** out of luck there. I mean, I think Big Thunder Mountain Railroad isn't that the same in Disney World and Disneyland? Unless humidity is a factor.
然后到底要坐多少次这个过山车？为了确保它管用，我们还得把所有的过山车都试一遍。另外，史密斯飞船那个在奥兰多，所以他们有预算飞去佛罗里达测试他们的实验。我想他们其实只在佛罗里达测试过。所以我确实很好奇，科林。你这次可真是走投无路了。我是说，巨雷山铁路在迪士尼世界和迪士尼乐园不都一样吗？除非湿度是一个影响因素。
Colin, we need you to go to Anaheim. Science, science. I have a question that's gonna make me sound really dumb. When you pass a kidney. Stone. Not the whole kidney. Not the whole kidney. When you pass a kidney stone, I knew stone.
科林，我们需要你去阿纳海姆。科学，科学。我有个问题，问出来会显得我很蠢。当你排出肾结石的时候。结石。不是整个肾。不是整个肾。当你排出肾结石的时候，我知道是结石。
I know, I know. When you pass a kidney stone, where does it come out? Your pee hole. You pee it out. Oh God. That's why it's so painful. Where, where does it come out? Your pee hole? You pee it out. Oh, god. That's why it's so painful. Where did you think it came out? I didn't know if you pooped it or peed it.
我知道，我知道。当你排出肾结石时，它是从哪儿出来的？你的尿道。你把它尿出来。哦天哪。怪不得那么疼。在哪儿，它是从哪儿出来的？你的尿道？你把它尿出来。哦，天哪。怪不得那么疼。你以为它是从哪儿出来的？我不知道你是拉出来的还是尿出来的。
I wasn't sure. OK. They give you a little sieve to catch it so that they can analyze what caused it. Yeah. So you meant to pee into a sieve for up to a month. Like a sock sieve? Like, what is a sieve?
我不确定。好吧。他们会给你一个小筛子来接住它，以便他们分析是什么原因导致的。对。所以你要连续长达一个月对着筛子尿尿。像袜子筛子一样？筛子是什么样的？
It's like a coffee filter. Oh, wow. Like if you're panning for gold. Got it. So here you are. It's incredibly painful. You have to pee that out and catch it all at the same time. I have a friend who routinely gets kidney stones.
就像一个咖啡滤纸。哦，哇。就像你在淘金一样。明白了。所以你得面对这一切。这极其痛苦。你必须把那东西尿出来，同时还要把它接住。我有个朋友经常得肾结石。
Oh, no. He's the one who told me about the Big Thunder Mountain Railroad thing. They have a thing where they can go in and zap them, but they'll only zap it if it's a certain size, like if it's too big to pass. And I just want to watch. And one of the ways they go in to zap it is through...
哦，不。就是他跟我说了巨雷山铁路那件事的。他们有一种方法可以进去把它们击碎，但他们只在结石达到一定尺寸时才击碎，比如如果太大排不出来的话。而且我只想看着。他们进去击碎结石的方法之一就是通过……
Do they go in through your piano? Oh. So you don't... I wondered, don't you just want to zap it? But I guess maybe you don't. They can also hit it with vibrations from somewhere and break it up that way. It all sounds awful.
他们是从你的尿道进去吗？哦。所以你不想……我在想，难道你不想直接击碎它吗？但我想也许你并不想。他们还可以从某处用振动波击中它，以此来把它粉碎。这一切听起来都太可怕了。
I guess you can be genetically predisposed, but also there's some diet stuff that can contribute as well. And we were talking about AI earlier during the break. And so I obviously went straight to AI for, why did I get these kidney stones? What did it say? And well, I just moved into a new place about a month ago with a grapefruit tree.
我想你可能是基因易感，但也有些饮食因素可能会导致这种情况。我们刚才在休息时讨论了人工智能。所以我显然直接去问人工智能了：我为什么会得这些肾结石？它怎么说？嗯，我大约一个月前刚搬到一个有西柚树的新地方。
And I've been juicing grapefruit for breakfast every day for the last month. And AI says grapefruit can cause it. I heard that. My doctor, not convinced by that. Not convinced. OK, your doctor's not convinced by the AI grapefruit diagnosis or the roller coaster cure.
而且过去一个月里，我每天早餐都榨西柚汁喝。人工智能说西柚会导致这个。我听说过这个。我的医生对这个说法并不信服。并不信服。好吧，你的医生对人工智能的西柚诊断或过山车疗法都不太信服。
He was more open to the roller coaster. Well, he's called Gary. Gary. Okay, let's call Gary. That's how I've had a Dr. Gary. Gary is the name of a guy that took me on a swamp tour in Louisiana. It's true. I feel like that Gary would be pro Big Thunder Mountain, though.
他对过山车更持开放态度。好吧，他叫加里。加里。好吧，我们给加里打个电话。我以前怎么没听过叫加里医生的。加里这个名字让我想起带我在路易斯安那州游沼泽的那个人。真的。我觉得那个加里会赞成去坐巨雷山。
100%. He agreed that there was exercises you could do and movements or dances that might help shake it out. So he was like, the roller coaster might work in that theory. That or maybe you need to go to a dancer-size class or? Maybe. You can't really picture me at a dancer-sized class, though, right? I sometimes get vertigo, and there's
百分之百。他同意有些运动可以做，或者有些动作或舞蹈可能有助于把它摇出来。所以他觉得从这个理论上讲，过山车可能管用。要么就是你得去上个舞蹈健身课或者？也许吧。不过你确实很难想象我去上舞蹈健身课对吧？我有时会有眩晕症，有
this maneuver that you can do to reset the crystal in your ear or something. My mom gets horrible vertigo. And we've had to help her drop her head off the back of a bed one time when we were in a hotel at a family reunion and roll her head. Yeah, Lee does it for me. We have this little video that we have saved and it shows him how to you lay your head like you said with coming off the bed and then you like rotate the head in this
这样一个动作你可以做，用来重置你耳朵里的耳石什么的。我妈妈有可怕的眩晕症。有一次我们在一个家庭聚会的酒店里，我们不得不帮她把头垂到床沿后面，然后晃动她的头。对，李帮我做这个。我们有一个保存的小视频，上面演示了你怎么把头放好——就像你说的从床沿垂下去，然后你像这样旋转头部
certain way and then the crystal goes. I don't know about this crystal but I'm also right now getting acupuncture for my hot flashes and it's's working. And I don't understand that either. I asked the doctor, I'm like, what is it doing exactly? And she said, it's like, it's unblocking your chi. I get acupuncture every month for like the past four or five years. Wow. In that time I've only been sick maybe twice.
用某种特定的方式，然后耳石就归位了。我不知道什么耳石不耳石的，但我现在也在做针灸来治疗更年期潮热，而且挺管用的。我也搞不懂这是为什么。我问医生，我说这到底是起什么作用的？她说，这就像是，这在疏通你的气。我过去四五年里每个月都做针灸。哇。在这期间我大概只生过两次病。
So do you just get general acupuncture? Most of the time I'm doing it for my back, because I just like so many people on computers and phones. So yeah, they sometimes do cupping and then they'll just stick like a ton of needles and then my acupuncturist goes, midnight and turns off the lights and leaves for an hour. And you get a little nap. Oh, that's so nice. It's really nice. I can't look at a phone
所以你只是做普通的针灸吗？大多数时候我是为了治背痛才做的，因为我和许多人一样经常对着电脑和手机。所以是的，他们有时会拔火罐，然后扎上一大堆针，接着我的针灸师就会说，到半夜了，然后关掉灯离开一个小时。你可以小睡一会儿。哦，太棒了。真的很好。我没法看手机
because I got needles in my back. Yeah. It's, I love it. Yeah. But yeah, I feel like so many people I know, they go into it being like, is this going to work? And then they come out being like, it works. I don't know how, but it's great. I did not think it was going to work. And so if believing in it is part of what makes it work,
因为我背上扎着针。对。我太喜欢了。对啊。但确实，我认识的好多人在尝试之前都会想：这真的管用吗？然后他们做完出来就会说：真的管用。我不知道为什么，但太棒了。我本来以为这不会管用。所以如果相信它正是让它管用的原因之一，
then I wasn't not on board, you know, when I went in. So I was fully skeptical. And within two sessions, almost all my hot flashes were gone but I have to keep up with it. I have to go every week. I tried spacing it out and I can go every other but not much longer. But it's like amazing, the amazing relief.
那我进去的时候也不是完全不信，你知道的。所以我一开始完全是个怀疑论者。但经过两次治疗后，我的潮热几乎全消失了。不过我得坚持下去。我得每周都去。我试过拉长间隔，可以每两周去一次，但再久就不行了。不过这效果真是惊人的缓解。
Angela, Sam, this has clearly become the medical episode. Anything you want to talk about? No, no, I'm fine. I'm fully for kidney cells. Um, how's your plantar fasciitis, Angela? A lot better. I got an incline board that I stand on. I put it at the kitchen counter.
安吉拉，萨姆，这显然成了医学专场了。你们还有什么想聊的吗？没有，没有，我挺好的。我对肾结石了解得很透彻。嗯，安吉拉，你的足底筋膜炎怎么样了？好多了。我买了一块斜面板踩在上面。我把它放在厨房柜台边。
It's a little piece of wood. I feel like you could make this if you were handy, but I bought one and I stand on. I put it at the kitchen counter. It's a little piece of wood. I feel like you could make this if you were handy, but I bought one and I stand on it. And it stretches out your entire calf muscle because that's what leads to your plantar fasciitis. And it's got like three settings. You can make it more and more inclined. And now Josh and the kids, we all stand on it.
这是一小块木头。我觉得如果你心灵手巧的话，你也能自己做一个，但我买了一块，然后站在上面。我把它放在厨房柜台边。这是一小块木头。我觉得如果你心灵手巧的话，你也能自己做一个，但我买了一块，然后站在上面。它能拉伸你的整个小腿肌肉，因为这才是导致你足底筋膜炎的原因。它有大约三个档位。你可以把它调得越来越倾斜。现在乔什和孩子们，我们大家都会站上去。
And kind of one of my favorite things is when people come over and they're like, what's this thing? Because it's right at the edge of the kitchen counter. And I'm like, we all stand on it. And kind of one of my favorite things is when people come over and they're like, what's this thing? Cause it's right at the edge of the kitchen counter. And I'm like, it's an incline board, stand on it. It stretches your calves. And people that stand on it, who clearly haven't stretched their calf in a long time,
而且我最喜欢的事情之一就是当别人来家里做客时，他们会问：这是什么东西？因为它就在厨房柜台的边缘。然后我就说：我们都站在这上面。我最喜欢的事情之一就是当别人来家里做客时，他们会问：这是什么东西？因为它就在厨房柜台的边缘。然后我就说：这是一个斜面板，站在上面。它能拉伸你的小腿。那些站上去的人，显然很久没有拉伸过小腿了，
they like stand on it and they go like, oh God. And I can now stand on it without like, at least the first setting, right? Like without any pain. So. That's awesome. How are you doing with touching your toes? Oh, pretty good.
他们一站上去就会说：哦天哪。现在我至少能在第一档不用……至少能完全不痛地站上去了。所以。太棒了。你摸脚趾做得怎么样了？哦，挺好的。
Look. This has been a goal of Angela's for a really long time. Hey, she's doing it. Wait, but when you stand up and then bend over and touch your toes, this was your goal. This was like literally your goal this year. She's doing it. You did it, lady.
看。这是安吉拉长期以来的一个目标。嘿，她做到了。等等，但当你站直然后弯腰去摸脚趾时，这就是你的目标。这简直是你今年的目标。她做到了。你做到了，女士。
I did it, yeah. The backs of your legs have just always been really tight. Really tight, I know. I think it's from some of your tennis because you do like these little sprints when you play tennis. Yeah, I also stretch a lot more now before tennis. Yeah.
我做到了，对。你腿的后侧一直以来都很紧绷。非常紧绷，我懂。我觉得这是因为你打网球的缘故，因为你打网球时会有那种短距离冲刺。对，我现在打网球前也会做更多拉伸了。对。
I do a lot of squats and I do calf stretches and I stretch like my thighs. Yeah, and then, oh, you know what? It's such a great stretch. OK. So I don't know if you guys can do this, but as soon as you start doing it, it gets easier and easier. So what I'm basically just going to do
我做了很多深蹲，小腿拉伸，还有大腿拉伸。对，然后，哦，你知道吗？这是一个超级棒的拉伸。好吧。我不知道你们能不能做到，但只要你开始做，它就会变得越来越容易。所以我基本上要做的就是
is go completely into a squat on the ground, and then just sit there and hold it. So it's really good for your quads active stretch for the front of your quads. And your hips. Yes. It's really good for your hips. Yeah, this is, we do this in yoga. I mean, I think I'm going to see what you're about to do.
完全蹲在地上，然后就坐在那儿保持住。这对你的股四头肌是一个很好的主动拉伸，针对股四头肌的前侧。还有臀部。是的。这对你的臀部真的很好。对，我们在瑜伽里也会做这个。我是说，我要看看你接下来要做什么。
Okay. She's getting, yep. Oh yeah. That's a yoga pose. It has a name. So I just sit like that. And it's easier when you have shoes on. When you don't have shoes on, it's harder. It's harder without shoes. Yeah.
好吧。她准备，没错。哦，是的。这是一个瑜伽体式。它有个名字。所以我只是那样坐着。穿着鞋会更容易一些。不穿鞋的时候会更难。不穿鞋更难。对。
Oh. Oh, you keep your heels on the ground. Yeah. Your heels have to stay on the ground. I can't do it with my heels on the ground. Yeah. I can do it with my heels on the ground now, barefoot. Nice.
哦。哦，你得让脚后跟贴地。对。你的脚后跟必须贴在地上。我脚后跟贴地做不到。对。我现在光着脚脚后跟也能贴地做到了。不错。
Lady, you had the goal this year as part of your New Year's resolution that you shared with me that it was gonna be the year of touching your toes. Look at you. Look at me go. Look at you go. Look at me go.
女士，你今年的目标作为你跟我分享的新年愿望之一，就是成为摸到脚趾的一年。看看你。瞧我这状态。瞧瞧你。瞧瞧我这状态。
You know what my next one is? What? Probably because I've been complaining about my turkey neck. Okay. So my algorithm on my phone knows now. And I constantly get these women of a certain age who are saying, you tired of that turkey neck? It's time to do your mouth stretches. And I signed up.
你知道我的下一个目标是什么吗？什么？大概是因为我一直在抱怨我的火鸡脖。好吧。所以手机上的算法现在知道了。我经常看到这些到了一定年龄的女性在说：你厌倦那个火鸡脖了吗？是时候做你的面部肌肉拉伸了。然后我报名了。
No, you didn't. This lady said, respond 28 to get my, all my steps. And it's like things like this. It's like, oh, ah, ah, ah. And you do this thing and it's gonna clear up my turkey neck. I cannot believe that you haven't told me this. I did it last night.
不，你没有。这个女士说，回复 28 来获取我的所有步骤。然后就像这样的动作。就像，哦，啊，哦，啊。你做这个动作，它就会消除我的火鸡脖。我简直不敢相信你没跟我说过这个。我昨晚做的。
I had had a glass of wine. I feel like that's encouraged. Okay. It says I'm gonna reclaim glass of wine. I feel like that's encouraged. OK. It says I'm going to reclaim my jawline. I don't think you are, because I saw these a year ago, and I was like, I'm going to start doing them. Have you been doing it? I did one day of it.
我当时喝了一杯酒。我觉得这应该受到鼓励。好吧。它说我要找回一杯酒。我觉得这应该受到鼓励。好吧。它说我要找回我的下颌线。我觉得你找不回，因为我一年前就看到过这些，当时我就想：我要开始练这个。你一直在练吗？我练了一天。
My jaw hurt so bad. That probably means you're activating the muscle. I gave it up. I think what's going to happen is I'm either going to have an amazing jaw line, or I'm going to get a real thick neck. I think you're going to get both. Maybe a thick, tight neck. It's going to be like something like, what's his face?
我的下巴疼得要命。那可能意味着你在激活那块肌肉。我放弃了。我觉得接下来会发生的事情是，要么我会有惊艳的下颌线，要么我的脖子会变得很粗。我觉得你两样都会得到。也许是一个粗壮紧致的脖子。看起来会有点像，什么来着？
Like, I'll be back. Yeah. He's got the all neck. What's the one where for photos you're meant to put the tongue on your top of your mouth Like something like, what's his face? Like, I'll be back. Yeah. He's got the all neck. What's the one where for photos you meant to put like the tongue on your top of your mouth and that gives you the jaw line? I don't know which one it is,
就像，我会回来的。对。他的脖子特别粗。拍照时应该把舌头顶在上腭，是什么来着？就像，我会回来的。对。他的脖子特别粗。拍照时应该把舌头顶在上腭，这样能练出下颌线，是哪个动作来着？我不知道是哪一个，
but that's like the selfie hack. Oh yeah, I saw that. I saw that. Have you seen the one about like how to get a great photo? Like a great candid photo is where you like, you all link arms and then you sort of like wobble forward. What? And you see all these people doing that online and then you see the photo they got. I want to try that. Is that just because everyone starts giggling? It's like a nice natural smile. Yes, exactly. Well, we have had
但那就像自拍秘诀。哦对，我看到了。我看到了。你见过那种关于如何拍出一张好照片的说法吗？比如一张绝佳的抓拍照片是这样的：你们所有人手挽着手，然后往前晃动。什么？你看到网上所有人都在这样做，然后你看到了他们拍出来的照片。我想试试那个。那是不是因为每个人都开始咯咯笑了？那就像是一个自然好看的微笑。对，没错。好吧，我们有
people comment that I never look at the camera lens. I don't think you do either. I think Sam and Cassie look at the right dot and you and I look somewhere else. Lady, like when we did our mashup, when we did our thing with PodMeetsWorld and we took a photo, the five of us, a selfie, they are all looking in the camera and you and I are not. And all of the comments are like,
粉丝评论说我从来不看相机镜头。我觉得你也没看。我觉得萨姆和卡茜看着正确的那个圆点，而你和我在看别的地方。女士，就像我们做串烧视频时，我们和《听世界》（PodMeetsWorld）一起合作拍了一张合照，我们五个人的一张自拍，他们全都在看着镜头，而你和我在看别的地方。所有的评论都在说：
we know who's old in this picture because they're not looking in the camera. And then now like one person commented recently on a post we did Angela, someone commented, dear God teach them how to look at the lens. Oh my God, it's really bothering people. I'm gonna try. You just have to point it out.
我们知道这张照片里谁老了，因为她们没看镜头。然后现在，比如最近有人在我们发的一条动态下面评论，安吉拉，有人评论说：天哪，教教她们怎么看镜头吧。哦天哪，这真的在困扰大家。我要试试。你只需要指出来。
The next time we take a picture. We'll take a picture today and we'll do our best with the wobbling forward. Yeah. Colin, you also said there's some thing where you flip your phone around now. Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
我们下次拍照的时候。我们今天拍张照片，然后我们会尽最大努力往前晃动。对。科林，你还说过现在有什么把手机翻转过来的技巧。对。我是说，我不知道。
It's like the tongue on the mouth thing. I know like half of it from an Instagram post. And it was just younger people saying put it to like 0.5 and flip it around. So you're using the front facing camera of the phone. But you don't know. You don't know if you've got yourself. You can't see if you're in frame front-facing camera of the phone. So you're taking the selfies. You don't know if you've got yourself. You can't see if you're in frame.
就像舌头顶上腭的那种。我知道 Instagram 帖子里的半截。就是一些年轻人说把它调到 0.5 倍然后翻转过来。所以你在用手机的前置摄像头。但你不知道。你不知道自己有没有拍进去。你看不见自己是不是在镜头里前置摄像头。所以你在自拍。你不知道自己有没有拍进去。你看不见自己是不是在构图内。
You have to have the confidence. That's kind of like old school when we would take selfies with our disposable cameras. Well, I guess it's the better camera on that side, and it gives you the option of different zooms. And then I've seen for the influencers, you can get a little screen that you stick on the other side of your phone.
你必须得有自信。这有点像老派的做法，以前我们用一次性相机自拍时那样。不过，我觉得那一面的摄像头更好，而且它提供了不同变焦的选项。然后我看到网红们可以买一个小屏幕贴在手机的另一侧。
Oh, so you can see the photo? So you've got a monitor, and you can see like a little screen that you stick on the other side of your phone. Oh, so you can see the photo? So you've got like a monitor and you can see the photo. People are really like, that's a lot. Good at that stuff. But it does look nicer, I think. The light or something. I think it does. The front lens is better than the selfie lens, which is surprising.
哦，这样你就能看到照片了？所以你有一个监视器，你可以看到——就像一个小屏幕贴在手机的另一侧。哦，这样你就能看到照片了？所以你就像有个监视器，能看到照片。人们真的是……那可真够复杂的。很擅长搞那些东西。但我觉得拍出来确实更好看。光线什么的。我觉得是的。前置镜头的画质比自拍镜头要好，这挺让人意外的。
You think we take so many selfies, they would design a better lens. What was the first selfie though? Because I feel like we didn't come up with, like I don't remember ever in my youth taking a selfie with a camera. I do. I remember we would turn it around and like just hope for the best. Digital camera. Yeah. But not like film disposable camera. I never like. I did one with a disposable camera. It was too precious. The film, like, yeah. In 1839, Robert Cornelius, a Philadelphia chemist and photography enthusiast took the world's first known photographic selfie.
你觉得我们拍了这么多自拍，他们应该设计一个更好的镜头才对。不过第一张自拍是什么时候的？因为我觉得我们不是自己想出来的——我不记得我年轻时用相机拍过自拍。我记得。我记得我们会把相机转过来，然后祈祷能拍好。数码相机。对。但不是那种胶片一次性相机。我从来没有……我用一次性相机拍过一次。太珍贵了。胶片，就像，对。1839 年，费城化学家兼摄影爱好者罗伯特·科尼利厄斯（Robert Cornelius）拍摄了世界上已知的第一张摄影自拍。
Wow. Sam, there you have it. Googling like crazy over there. And he just knew that. Yeah, yeah, he just knew it off the dome. All right, well, this has been a very interesting Friday chit-chat, Colin. I might need you back. Yes, please go to Disneyland.
哇。萨姆，你看吧。在那儿疯狂地用谷歌搜索呢。而且他本来就知道。对，对，他张口就来。好吧，这真是一次非常有趣的周五闲聊，科林。我可能还想再请你来。好的，请去迪士尼乐园吧。
Yeah, we're all going to Disneyland, right? Yeah, we're all going to Disneyland. Yeah, and we're going to pass that stone. I'm sorry you have to pass that out. As a team, we are going to pass it. We are. That's the spirit. Dr. Gary says that's not the bit to worry about.
对，我们都要去迪士尼乐园，对吧？对，我们都要去迪士尼乐园。对，我们要把那块结石排出来。很遗憾你得把它排出来。作为一个团队，我们要把它排出来。我们会的。这才是精神。加里医生说那不是最需要担心的部分。
The pain is like the blockage beforehand. It's like when it's still in your kidney and when it's coming down your internal tubes. Well, I mean, we'll see if he's lying to me. Gary? Dr. Gary. But also, he's like, the kidney stones don't hurt. And it's like, fine if they're just
疼痛就像是之前的阻塞。就像它还在你的肾里以及顺着你的内部管道下来的时候。好吧，我的意思是，我们拭目以待他是不是在骗我。加里？加里医生。但他也说，肾结石本身并不疼。而且就像，如果它们只是
the nice little round ones. But there's a kind of kidney stone called a staghorn. No. Kidney stone. And it's got prongs? It's got spikes. Yeah. Seems like that'd hurt.
那种好看的小圆石头的话倒还好。但有一种肾结石叫鹿角状结石。不。肾结石。它有分叉？它有尖刺。对。听起来就很疼。
How could it not hurt? Colin, you're just sitting around just in anticipation of excruciating pain. That is such a mind f***. But would this be better on a Disneyland ride? Yeah. I wonder. I want to scream on this ride, Colin.
怎么可能不疼呢。科林，你现在就坐在那里静候剧烈的疼痛。这简直太让人精神崩溃了。但这在迪士尼乐园的过山车上会好点吗？对。我在想。我想在这个过山车上尖叫，科林。
I can have a little photo memorizing the moment. Yes, exactly. All right, everybody. That was our Friday chit chat. Have a good weekend. Yeah. See ya. Bye. Bye.
我可以拍张照片来纪念这一刻。对，没错。好了，各位。这就是我们今天的周五闲聊。祝你们周末愉快。拜拜。再见。拜拜。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由杰娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡茜·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是里奇·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。